meantime i wanted to take a moment to  say hey the mojave max desert tortoise  school assemblies are back on we started  the season yesterday talking to the  second graders at vail pittman  elementary school miss zarpas and her  second graders and then the assistant  principal volunteered to put on the  desert tortoise costume to help the kids  learn about mojave max and desert  tortoise now elementary kids are allowed  to enter the mojave max emergence  contest to guess when the real max wakes  up out at the springs preserve go to  mojavemax.com for a chance to win a  laptop computer a pizza party and a trip  to the springs preserve john